من دون مقدمات دخلتها حياتنا واصبحت
امتدادا لذواتنا صديقتين عبقريتين تملكان
الاجوبه لاي سؤال والخرائط لاي وجهه
تختزنان عوالم وفضاءات تقرب البعيد وتمد
جسورا بين البشر لكنك لن تجد الموده
بينهما
[موسيقى]
تتنافس شركه ابل وجوجل بهدوء منذ سنوات
لكن طبول حربيهم صامته بدات التدوي فشركه
ابل تخوض معارك لتعزيز خدمات ايفون وتفطمه
عن ميزات تقدمها شركه اثبت الشركه الام
لجوجل
[موسيقى]
صحيفه في عين سلطان نقلت عن مهندسين
سابقين قولهما ان صناعه ايفون اعلنوا
الحرب على جوجل من خلال تطوير انظمه
الخرائط والبحث والاعلانات
[موسيقى]
ها على جوجل اكثر فاكثر
ستواصل جوجل توسعها وتطورها لكن الاكيد هو
ان الصراع بينهما يعني اننا سنحصل على
هواتف اكثر ذكاء واسرع واشد حمايه
لخصوصياتنا لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]